well the main protest over this visit is
happening miles away in London this
morning political groups that oppose the
president have spent months preparing
for this this is live footage right now
of these protests Elizabeth Homer went
out to see the demonstrators and who are
they're denouncing and mocking the
president thousands of protesters have
now marched right through central London
and they're rallying now outside
Britain's Parliament organizers believe
that as many as 70,000 people will join
in which would make this the largest
weekday protest in London for 15 years
since huge crowds marched against the
American invasion of Iraq the
demonstrators are opposed to mr. Trump's
very presence in Britain as well as his
policies everything from immigration to
trade to climate change many of them the
Britons in the crowd took time off work
to join the March but there are people
here from all over the world as well
including Americans
some UK politicians argued that the
protest was a disrespectful way to greet
the President of the United States on an
official visit and for months the
British government has worked on mr.
Trump's schedule to make sure he didn't
have to come anywhere near these crowds
but that hasn't dimmed the mood one bit
the protesters are sure that eventually
one way or another mr. Trump will see
and hear them on TV for CBS this morning
I'm Elizabeth Palmer in London